لذلك دعونا نتحدث عن الانتقال الآن
والأهم بعد إصابته بسكتة دماغية
نعلم أنه كان بعيدًا عن الأنظار إلى حد كبير
وقد رأيناه بالفعل
يطلق مشروعًا أثناء الخفاء
رأيناه يعلق أه
ويحتفل على وجه التحديد بلحظات مهمة جدًا
ولكن دي  القائد الفعلي لما
نفهمه هو ولي العهد
محمد بن زايد
منذ
إصابته بسكتة دماغية ، وهذا صحيح تمامًا ،
لذا هل ستكون هناك استمرارية فيما
يتعلق بالسياسة والقيادة ، وأعتقد أنه
سيكون هناك استمرارية هائلة ،
إنه
شيء يتوقعه الجميع.  كان يتوقع
منذ
سنوات عديدة أنه عندما
توفي الشيخ خليفة أخيرًا ، سيخلفه الشيخ محمد
كما كان منصوصًا عليه قبل
وفاة والدهم في عام 2004.
لذلك هناك استمرارية هناك
استقرار ليس هناك مخاوف
على الإطلاق من المهم أن نلاحظ في
الواقع أن  كان الأب المؤسس
قد اختار ولي العهد يدويًا ، لذا كان
الشيخ خليفة في ذلك الوقت وأيضًا تم
اختياره يدويًا محمد بي.  ن زايد
أوضح تمامًا ما يريده ، نعم ،
نحن نعرف خط الخلافة
ماذا سيحدث بعد ذلك لأن هذا نوعًا ما
الآن السؤال الكبير هو أنه
شيء نطرحه في هذه المرحلة من الوقت
جيدًا ، وأول شيء يحدث
هو أن  يجب أن يجتمع مجلس حكام أه السبعة
غدًا في اليوم
التالي لوظيفتهم اختيار رئيس جديد
من بين
عددهم مؤقتًا نائب الرئيس الشيخ
محمد بن راشد من دبي ، وهو
أيضًا رئيس الوزراء الذي يتولى
منصب
الرئيس بالإنابة.  يجب ملء المنصب الشاغر في
غضون 30 يومًا وفقًا للدستور